hablemos sobre la entropía de enlace y
cómo podemos usarla para calcularla
entalpía de la reacción la entalpía de
enlace es la energía que se necesita
para romper un molde un enlace
mol de un enlace y diferentes tipos de
enlaces tendrán diferentes central pías
de enlace veamos un ejemplo hablemos de
un enlace carbono hidrógeno o mejor
dicho de un enlace simple carbono
hidrógeno este carbono probablemente
está unido a otras cosas porque
recordemos que los carbonos tienen más
enlaces simples pero por el momento
vamos a ignorar todo lo demás que esté
unido al carbón y vamos a representarlo
como una gran mancha puede ser una
proteína o una molécula de glucosa puede
ser muchas cosas pero vamos a ignorar
eso y algo que se me estaba olvidando
mencionar es que esta es la energía que
se necesita para romper un molde de un
enlace en estado gaseoso
en estado gaseoso esta es una muy buena
definición entonces en el caso de un
enlace carbono hidrógeno si rompemos
este enlace tenemos que agregar energía
y como productos obtenemos todo lo que
ignoramos y al romper este enlace de los
dos electrones que originalmente
teníamos uno de los electrones se va con
el carbono y el otro electrón se va con
el hidrógeno y a los electrones libres
los representamos así con un punto
por ejemplo cuando dibujamos estructuras
de louis acuérdense que representamos un
par de electrones libres con dos puntos
entonces aquí tenemos el carbono con un
punto es decir un electrón y al
hidrógeno con otro electrón ambos se
encuentran en estado gaseoso
así que delta h para esta reacción es
igual a la entropía de enlace que la voy
a abreviar como eh
entonces algunas cosas importantes que
debemos recordar son que la entalpía de
enlace siempre es positiva siempre vamos
a necesitar energía vamos a tener que
agregar energía para romper un enlace y
si tomamos la entalpía de enlace inversa
es decir si invertimos la reacción
entonces estaríamos formando un enlace
formamos un enlace y como sabemos que
para romper un enlace siempre
necesitamos energía entonces al formar
un enlace siempre se libera energía así
siempre tendremos una entalpía negativa
cuando se forma un enlace y esa es otra
forma de decir que se libera energía y
el tercer punto que vamos a ver sobre la
entropía de enlace es que podemos usarla
podemos usarla entalpía de enlace para
estimar delta
h de la reacción y delta h la entropía
de la reacción es algo que nos interesa
mucho a los químicos porque queremos
saber si la reacción es exotérmica o
endo térmica y tal vez ustedes conozcan
muchas otras formas de calcular delta h
como por ejemplo usando la ley de hesse
o también usando la delta h de formación
y existen otras formas esta es sólo una
forma en la que podemos calcular la
entalpía de la reacción usando la
central pies de enlace veamos un ejemplo
supongamos que tenemos una reacción de
propinó que es de 3 h 4 en estado
gaseoso que reacciona con hidrógeno
gaseoso para obtener propano c3 h 8
gracioso y no sé ustedes pero a mí se me
dificulta un poco ver la forma de las
moléculas solamente con la fórmula
química entonces déjenme dibujar las
estructuras del
ok el propi no tiene 3 carbonos y un
triple enlace carbono carbono y después
tenemos 4 hidrógenos
este es el pro pino también tenemos
hidrógeno gaseoso y nuestro producto es
propano todos los enlaces del propano
son enlaces simples entonces tenemos 3
carbonos unidos con enlaces simples
y unidos a esos carbonos tenemos 8
hidrógenos
esta es la reacción que nos interesa y
lo que queremos saber es cuál es la
delta h de la reacción
como podríamos calcularla usando la
central pies de enlace bueno ya habíamos
dicho que la antártida de enlace es la
energía que se necesita para romper un
enlace así que lo que podemos hacer es
analizar nuestra reacción e identificar
cuáles son los enlaces que se forman y
cuáles son los que se rompen y eso es
más fácil con las estructuras de louis
entonces primero veamos cuáles son los
enlaces que se rompen
miren si comparamos los reactivos con el
producto podemos ver que se rompe este
triple enlace carbono carbono y también
se rompe este enlace hidrógeno hidrógeno
y una cosa que olvidamos antes y que es
bien importante necesitamos asegurarnos
antes de cualquier cosa que las
reacciones de balanceada vamos a ver
aquí tenemos 426 hidrógenos del lado de
los reactivos pero tenemos 8 hidrógenos
del lado de los productos así que
necesitamos
dos moléculas de hidrógeno gaseoso vamos
a dibujar la segunda
ok entonces dijimos que se rompe el
enlace hidrógeno hidrógeno pero en
realidad estamos rompiendo dos enlaces
hidrógeno hidrógeno y aquí lo que nos
importa es saber cuántos tipos de
enlaces estamos rompiendo porque la
entropía de enlace es por mol entonces
si tenemos el doble de moles
necesitaremos el doble de energía para
romper esos enlaces ok ahora veamos los
enlaces que se formen miren como se
rompe el triple enlace carbono carbono
se crea un enlace nuevo que en la
molécula de nuestro producto corresponde
a este enlace simple carbono carbono y
no solamente formamos ese enlace sino
que también ahora esos carbonos están
unidos a hidrógenos así que formamos
cuatro nuevos enlaces carbono hidrógeno
vamos a escribirlo para que no se nos
olvide cuando hagamos el cálculo de
delta h de la reacción entonces los
enlaces que se rompen son se rompe un
triple enlace carbono carbono y dos
enlaces hidrógeno hidrógeno
también escribamos cuántos son porque
eso también lo vamos a necesitar
entonces se rompe un triple enlace
carbono carbono y dos enlaces hidrógeno
hidrógeno ok y ahora veamos sustenta al
pies de enlace que están en kilo jules
por morir
la entropía de enlace que normalmente
podemos encontrar en un libro o en
internet generalmente se encuentran en
tablas de entalpía de enlaces y las
unidades pueden estar en kiel o goerges
por mol o también puede que las
encuentren en calorías o kilocalorías
por mol
yo ya busque los valores de la entropía
para estos enlaces y encontré que el
triple enlaces carbono-carbono tiene una
entalpía de enlace de 835 kilos jules
formol y el enlace hidrógeno hidrógeno
tiene una entalpía de enlace de 436
kilos formal ahora si analizamos los
enlaces que se forman tenemos
un enlace simple carbono carbono y solo
se forma uno y la entropía de enlace
también en kilo jules por mol es de 346
y finalmente se forma el enlace carbono
hidrógeno y se forman 4 enlaces y para
cada uno la antártida de enlace es de
413 kilos jules formol ok ahora ya
podemos usar toda esta información para
calcularla entalpía de la reacción
entonces delta h de la reacción si
pensamos en los enlaces que se rompen y
se forman es la energía que se necesita
para romper los enlaces de los reactivos
en este caso para romper el triple
enlace carbono carbono y los dos enlaces
hidrógeno hidrógeno más la energía que
se necesita para formar nuevos enlaces
para formar los nuevos enlaces de
nuestro producto y ya habíamos dicho que
para romper los enlaces siempre
necesitamos agregar energía así que esta
parte de nuestra ecuación es positiva y
por lo tanto como al formar nuevos
enlaces siempre se libera energía esta
parte es negativa cuando hablamos de la
energía que se necesita para formar
nuevos enlaces esta parte debe de ser
negativa ok ahora vamos a sustituir los
valores de la central pías de los
enlaces que se forman y se rompen en
nuestra reacción empecemos con los
enlaces que se rompen tenemos el triple
enlace carbono carbono que necesita 835
kilos por mol y sólo tenemos 1 y también
necesitamos romper 12 enlaces hidrógeno
hidrógeno entonces 2 por 436 kilo jules
por mol que es la entropía de enlace
para este caso entonces esto
los enlaces que se rompen pero ahora
vamos a agregar la energía que se libera
al formar nuevos enlaces tenemos un
enlace carbono carbono que corresponde a
346 kilos por mol y esto es negativo
porque esa energía es liberada y
finalmente tenemos el enlace carbono
hidrógeno también con signo negativo
porque esa energía liberada y en este
caso tenemos 4 cada enlace liberar a una
energía de 413 kilos jules dormal ok y
si calculamos todo esto para obtener
nuestra respuesta final lo que yo obtuve
fue que delta h para esta reacción de
hidrogenación entre el propinó y el
hidrógeno gaseoso es igual a menos 291
kilos por mol
por lo tanto como delta h es negativa
podemos decir que se libera energía así
que la reacción es exotérmica
exotérmica así es como podemos usarlas
cental pías de los enlaces para calcular
delta h de la reacción